hi everyone I'm Steve Brenton and I'm
going to talk about a compressed
overview of sparsity so I'm going to
talk about compressed sensing and
sparsity and broadly speaking I'm going
to talk about compressed sensing and
sparsity as they relate to complex
engineering systems so dynamical systems
systems the vary in time that are high
dimensional with multi scale structure
in space and time
so in this most examples I'm going to
use our fluids oriented but really these
ideas of the sparsity of data and the
compressibility and compressed sensing
of data apply to lots of engineering
systems and dynamical systems beyond
where these ideas are kind of originated
in statistics and image science and I'd
like to acknowledge my collaborators who
I'm working with closely on these ideas
of compressed suppressed sensing and
sparsity in engineering systems and so
there are other collaborators but these
are are kind of my main collaborators on
the topics in this in this presentation
so what I want to do is give you a
high-level overview of compressed
sensing but I want to frame it in terms
of old ideas of sparsity and
compressibility of signals so here we're
going to talk about compression versus
compressed sensing and I'm first just
going to tell you about image
compression or signal compression
because we use it every day if you
listen to an mp3 audio or you send a
picture to your friend or you watch
satellite TV you're you're interacting
with compressed data and the reason that
we're able to to communicate these very
large large datasets is essentially
because they are compressible so the
idea here is let's say I have it's
really easy to illustrate this on an
example so let's say I take a megapixel
image that's just 1 million pixels
roughly if I fast Fourier transform so
here I'm plotting the magnitude of
Fourier coefficients in 2d it turns and
this is on a log-log scale it turns out
that most of these Fourier coefficients
are very very small kind of background
noise with a
few large values and if I zero out all
of the background small Fourier
coefficients that's what's happened in
this third panel where I've zeroed out
all but one or two percent of the
largest coefficients when I inverse
Fourier transform I essentially get
exactly the same image as before okay so
what this means is that only one or two
percent or a very small amount of these
Fourier coefficients are actually
necessary to be nonzero to encode the
information in this very large megapixel
image this is the basis of JPEG image
compression so instead of storing a
million numbers of these the pixel
values at a million locations all I have
to do is store the locations and
magnitudes of one or two percent of my
nonzero Fourier coefficients then when
you want to open that file it
essentially just does the inverse
Fourier transform and shows it to you in
pixel space which is where we like to
see images okay this is decades old
people have been using this idea of
compressibility of signals for a long
time and the idea here is that the fact
that this image is compressible means
that in some basis like Fourier the
representation is sparse most of the
elements are zero and there's only a few
important nonzero elements so we're
going to be talking a lot about sparse
vectors and sparse matrices and this is
so you should think about this in terms
of compressibility so if a vector or a
matrix is sparse and some transform
basis it's compressible and fortunately
for us almost all signals that we're
ever going to come in contact with
unless they've already been compressed
are compressible so any natural image
any audio signal fluid velocity field
even a turbulent or really messy one is
inherently compressible okay the only
things that aren't compressible are
things that have already been compressed
and things that look like TV static okay
kind of like random random noise so the
idea of compressed sensing which is
different than compression is instead of
measuring all of these million pieces of
information just to discard most of them
after compression why don't I start
off by only measuring say 10% random
measurements so maybe just only measure
10% random pixels of my original image
and see if I can use those measurements
to infer what my few nonzero fourier
coefficients had to be to be consistent
with these these measurements okay so
this is not a complicated idea instead
of just measuring a million things
throwing away 99% of them let's measure
a dramatic sub sample of this
information and try to infer what the
important nonzero fourier coefficients
were in the first place okay now this is
a pretty difficult problem and even
though we could have we could have tried
this decades earlier it's really recent
advances in compressed sensing and l1
minimization and convex optimization
routines that make this computationally
possible so that's what I'm going to
talk about a little bit but before
before getting into the nitty-gritty
nuts and bolts of compressed sensing I
want to give you just a feeling why is
it that all natural images and signals
are compressible why are they sparse in
a transform basis so this is one of my
favorite favorite topics to talk about
because it's so neat to think about how
utterly vast signal spaces so in this
case I'm going to talk about images
we're talking about pixel space but you
can think about your problem so if I
have a fluid velocity field I have all
these degrees of freedom I have them
it's it's basically like a picture of my
fluid and so it's a lot like pixel space
so the example I like to give about how
vast pixel space is is consider a twenty
by twenty a dinky little image that has
20 pixels by 20 pixels and each of those
pixels could just be black or white so
I'll actually draw this up so let's say
I have some some image and every single
pixel in here can either be black or
white and let's say that for simplicity
I have 20 pixels by 20 pixels how many
possible dinky little 20 by 20
black-and-white images are could I
possibly have
well there's 400 pixels and each of
those pixels can be turned on or off
kind of independently of the other ones
and so I have two to the power four
hundred possible dinky little twenty by
twenty images now two to the four
hundred of these these little twenty by
twenty images is more than the nucleons
the number of nucleons in the known
universe
okay so pixel space is bigger than
astronomical and that was just a dinky
little twenty by twenty image what about
a megapixel image with lots of color
depth instead of black and white I can
have all of you shades of gray or color
or even hyperspectral so image space
pixel space is vast that's beyond vast
and every natural image every image that
you could ever see with your two eyes
lives in a teeny tiny little corner of
image space so think about this this
image space of a megapixel image is so
vast there is a picture of what you're
seeing right now there's a picture of
what I'm seeing right now there's a
picture of you being born from different
perspectives from different cameras that
never existed image space is vast but
all natural images everything you would
ever lay your eyes on a picture of a
human a mountain a stream that lives in
a tiny tiny corner a very structured
corner of image space now how can I say
that this lives in a tiny corner if it's
vast enough to contain every image you'd
ever see in your entire life well do
this thought experiment let's say I take
my megapixel image and I start randomly
assigning pixel values to all of those
million pixels what is it what am I
going to get well I'm going to get
something that looks like TV static kind
of like this gray background noise and I
challenge you that if you randomly
sampled random images from this million
dimensional pixel space you could do
this until the end of the universe and
you'll never come up with a picture of a
stream or a hurricane or a mountain or
anything that is natural so that's
another way of considering that even
though natural image space is that
unstructured pixel space is much faster
still and so image space lives in this
tiny structured corner of a pixel space
okay and that's why we can expect that
in some appropriate Fourier transform or
wavelet transform basis these images
might in fact be sparse and
representable with much less information
than their exact pixel value and that's
really the idea here in compress sensing
is that if I have an appropriate
transform basis so here that's given by
this matrix I in this case it's like a
discrete Fourier transform if I write my
vector my signal so in this case I made
me take my image and I turn it into a
big tall million dimensional vector if I
write that vector in Fourier transform
coefficients that's this big a vector
most of the coefficients are 0 and this
is a sparse vector and we call it K
sparse if there's exactly K nonzero
entries in this vector so the problem is
instead of just measuring all of my
million pixels in my my measurement
vector X and then compressing and
throwing away a bunch of it can I
measure a subsample of that information
in some measurement vector Y that's much
smaller than a million pixels and then
can I infer what this sparse vector of
coefficients had to be okay and if you
think about this matrix system on the
right y equals theta a this is really
just a big matrix system of equations I
have measurements y equals some matrix
some measurement matrix times a sparse
vector ok so this is like an ax equals b
linear algebra problem and what we're
trying to do is find the sparse
aspossible a that's consistent with
these measurements Y now you'll think
about this there are there's more
unknowns in a than there are constraints
in Y so there's probably infinitely many
possible solution vectors a that satisfy
these measurements so in some sense you
might say this is an ill-posed problem
there's so many different a is how could
I possibly select one we're looking for
the sparse as possible a because it
turns out that most
our sparse and unappropriate transform
basis so we want to do this kind of
constrained optimization to find a
sparse inspector a that is consistent
with with this measurement vector Y of
and this measurement vector could be
obtained by taking my megapixel image
and just randomly sampling a few percent
of those pixels and stacking them into a
vector okay so again we could have done
this problem before we could have
written this down as a search of all
sparse vectors a that are consistent
with these measurements but before the
advent of compressed sensing before
about a decade ago this would have been
a combinatorially hard search okay and
what do I mean by combinatorially hard
search what I mean is if my my search
space this million you know this
n-dimensional very high dimensional
vector space if I know that I have K
nonzero entries I would basically have
to try all possible K nonzero vectors
and so I'd have an N choose K problem or
a million choose 10,000 which we all
know that that's that's combinatorially
difficult and I would never have any
chance of ever searching through all of
those vectors to find the sparseness one
so one of the really special things
about compressed sensing and this was
proved by can des Romberg tau and also
by Donahoe and others there were various
aspects that were proved by them in
around 2006 is that with high
probability I can find the sparse vector
a that satisfies this this system of
equations if I minimize the one norm of
a okay so the one norm is not an exact
measure of sparsity of a vector the one
norm adds up the absolute value of every
component so you could imagine that if a
bunch of my entries of a are zero I
would get a small one norm but the one
norm is now a proxy for the sparsity of
the vector a and for very high
dimensional systems and for sufficiently
many good measurements and I'll tell you
what good and sufficiently many mean
a minute with high probability if I find
the l1 minimum solution a that satisfies
the system that will be this Farkas
vector okay so this is really special
because finding the the a vector that
has a minimal one norm and satisfies
this matrix system is a convex
optimization it scales it scales with
Moore's law so if I get bigger data all
I have to do is wait a couple years and
my computer will be faster and I can
solve it that's not true of
combinatorial searches and this is a
really important point that compressed
sensing makes these problems searchable
in in some kind of a convex optimization
scheme so that's some theory I want to
give you a concrete example this is an
example I have MATLAB code you can
download this and try it yourself it's
very simple only a few lines what we're
going to do is we're going to use this
compress sensing idea to find to
essentially reconstruct a signal from
under sampled measurements now when I
give this talk to engineering crowds I
either get really excited audience at
this point because they know about
Shannon Nyquist sampling theorem and
they know that there are fundamental
limits on how fast or how often I have
to sample a signal depending on what the
highest frequency component in that
signal is and when I tell them that we
can actually beat the Shannon Nyquist
sampling theorem with compressed sensing
I either get really excited a really
excited audience or I gets cowls and
hisses and so I hope that I can convince
you that this is there's no magic here
there this is just simple linear algebra
and compressed sensing okay so the
signal I want to reconstruct is a sum of
two signs one of them has frequency 73
Hertz the other one has a frequency 531
Hertz
Shannon Nyquist tells me that if I want
to adequately resolve this signal I need
to measure it at at least 1062 samples
per second now Shannon Nyquist is true
for broadband signals or for in some
sense for signals that are already
compressed and dense full of information
so Shannon Nyquist is absolute
right if I had a broadband signal I
would need 1062 samples per second but
if you look at the power spectrum of
arson signal it's not broadband at all
it's got two peaks ultra ultra sparse in
Fourier most of the coefficients are 0
and I've got two Peaks so for sparse
signals in some appropriate transform
basis I can beat Shane and Nyquist with
compressive sampling or compressed
sensing so in this case I'm down
sampling by almost a factor of 10 so I'm
measuring these red X's and the catch is
that I can't measure them at uniform
intervals I have to measure them with a
random spacing and the average sample
rate is 128 samples per second and then
if I take these red measurements I can
apply this compress sensing l1
minimization so I can find the sparsit's
Fourier coefficients F hat that are
consistent with my few red measurements
and when I do that I get almost perfect
signal reconstruction and very very good
agreement in my power spectrum okay this
kind of demystifies this it's just a few
lines of MATLAB code you can build the
signal measure these red X's apply the
l1 minimization and actually get the
signal reconstruction that before we
were told you couldn't you couldn't do
so I really like this example I hope you
try it out okay so going back we know
that signals are sparse in an
appropriate transform basis fortunately
for us as engineers most signals are
sparse in Fourier or wavelets as long as
they're not highly kind of localized so
as long as my my signal isn't just
defined by a few Delta functions it's
probably going to be sparse and for
wavelets and so we can get away with
with using measurements that are good
for Fourier and it turns out that single
pixel measurements are good for for
compressed sensing in a Fourier
transform because if I have a single
pixel measurement or a delta function in
space its broadband and frequency and so
it excites a little bit of all of my 4a
frequencies and if I have enough of
these single pixel measurements
I can get a read on which of my fourier
coefficients were nonzero okay so that's
just a and that's really nice so as an
engineer when I think of a measurement
I'm usually placing a sensor at a fixed
location so I might drop a buoy in the
ocean or I might if I have a wing I
might have a strain sensor at a few
locations and so for me single pixel or
spatially localized measurements are
really useful and fortunately these are
good compressed measurements if my
signal is sparse and for a so that's
really good for us interestingly along
the the lines of some of these proofs
and compressed sensing it turns out that
if I had a Gaussian random measurement
matrix so I basically take my my signal
X my high dimensional vector and i dot
it with a bunch of gaussian random
vectors those are good measurements
regardless of what my basis is my sparse
defying basis so even if you don't know
how or where your signal is sparse you
could take random kind of compressed
measurements and with high probability
you could reconstruct your signal so
that's a very cool results
mathematically very beautiful but for us
as engineers we really want to think a
lot about single pixel measurements so
l1 minimization and sparsity have been
around for for way longer than
compressed sensing right we talked about
image compression this is decades old
and these ideas of sparsity and l1
minimization have been used also for
decades for example in robust statistics
an outlier rejection so I just want to
give you a kind of a few a few examples
that illustrate why l1 is special okay
so here I have a bunch of blue data
points and I have a red outlier so we
all have data like this we have nice
beautiful clean data we painstakingly
gathered there's always at least an
outlier that you could have done a
better job or maybe the sensor
malfunction that day or maybe you just
have you have big outliers in your data
so if I showed you this data and I asked
you you know by I and humans are amazing
at casting out outliers if I asked you
by eye you might say that the best fit
line the regression line
for this data is something like this
white - line it looks fairly reasonable
now if I do a least-squares regression
all right if I do some kind of a least
squares fitting of all of these data
points this outlier is going to
massively skew the prediction line away
from the truth now why does this happen
the reason is is because I'm trying to
find the red dashed line that minimizes
the sum of the squared distance of all
of my points and this outlier is if I
square the distance of my outlier from
this red line that's so big because I'm
squaring it it tilts the entire fit
towards that outlier so I get this bad
robustness of my regression or my
statistics to an outlier and this is a
well-known a very like historically
well-known problem with with least
squares or l2 regression and so if we
minimize instead of LDL - distance of
every data point to our fit instead if
we minimize the l1 distance or fit we
get this beautiful blue dashed line
which fits the data much much better and
is robust to this sparse few outliers so
I have a little MATLAB code this is
really simple it's essentially just a
few lines to generate the data test out
these different fits using convex
optimization and you should get an idea
of how robust this l1 norm is to these
sparse outlier events ok so people have
known about l1 and sparsity and
robustness for a long time this is being
used right now in robust principal
components analysis so if you have a big
data matrix and you have lots of you
know a few sparse bad pixels or bad
measurements or outliers
you can fill in the gaps using these
kinds of robust statistics robust
principal components analysis which are
built on things like the sparsity
promoting l1 norm very cool very useful
in engineering so another kind of visual
description of why the l1 may
zatia niz sparse to be promoting so this
is another example you can code up and
just play around with it yourself
so remember most of our compressed
sensing problems we're going to end up
writing them as a matrix system of
equations ax equals B or it's really a
equals Y but at the end of the day I
have some vector which is sparse I want
to find a sparse vector that satisfies
this system of equations and usually I
have less elements of B than I do in X
so to some extent this is an under
constrained problem and I have enough
degrees of freedom there's infinitely
many solutions so you can cook this up
yourself you can make an a matrix which
is a random 200 by 1,000 matrix okay so
basically that means that X is a
thousand dimensional vector you hit it
with a and you get a 200 dimensional
vector out and so B is a 200 dimension
dimensional random vector so X has a
thousand elements this system has 200
constraints and if I do an l2 minimum
norm solution or a least squared
solution I can do this in MATLAB by just
taking the pseudo inverse of a times B
the l2 minimum norm solution is going to
give a little bit of a coefficient in
all of the entries of X so this thousand
dimensional X vector none of them are
going to be exactly zero and here's a
histogram of the coefficients in X you
see that it's kind of this Gaussian and
you know not many of them are zero most
of them are nonzero and if I do this L
one minimum norm solution so I solved
the exact same system of equations but
now instead of finding the least square
sorry that the the minimum two norm
solution I'm trying to find the minimum
one norm solution of X I get this
distribution of coefficients of X and
you see that almost all of the
coefficients of X are 0 in fact 800 of
them are 0 and you get exactly 200
nonzero constraints okay that's that's
how many cuts how many nonzero entries
are necessary to satisfy these 200
constraints so this is just a graphical
illustration of how the l1 norm promotes
sparsity whereas l2 does not promote
sparsity you can code this up and try it
out there's actually a great description
of this in Nathan coats's text which is
kind of where I got the inspiration for
this example and here is another
graphical illustration of the two norm
the circle versus the one norm this
diamond okay this is from a Siam review
in 2013 so if I look at a level set of
the two norm so all points in two space
that have the same two norm I get a
circle right these all have the same the
same distance from the origin in the two
norm right circle has every point has
the same distance from the origin but if
instead I use the one norm which is
essentially the absolute value of all
the components what I find is that now
my level set of the one norm is given by
this spiky looking diamond okay and if I
thought about what the zero norm it's
not actually norm but the zero pseudo
norm looked like it would essentially
look like a plus sign so I would get you
know a 1 so my level sets of the zero
norm would just look like a plus sign
they'd have a value at the plus 1 0
minus 1 0 0 plus 1 0 minus 1 ok so now
let's say that I have some some data and
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
find the l2 minimum norm solution and
the l1 minimum norm solution that
satisfies that data on given by this
line here so notice that the point where
this line intersects the minimum two
norm solution there's a little component
in X and a little component in Y so this
thing is not sparse it's got its got
some components in every direction or
because those two norm intersects at
some point on the circle but if I take
that exact same data and I look at where
it intersects this this one norm so
where the minimum 1 norm solution is it
tends to intersect at these sparse
points where there's just an entry in Y
but zeros and X or just an entry and X
but zeros and y and you can see that it
would actually be very difficult to have
this
data fall exactly in between one of
these sparse solutions where there's you
know zero and X but something in Y or
zero and Y and something in X so this is
just a pictorial representation of why
the l1 norm promotes sparsity because
when I do this fitting I usually end up
getting just one of my variables that's
needed to to describe that data very
cool a picture it's fun to think about
this in a higher dimension right in a
million dimensions I still have this
this hyper sphere and this kind of hyper
diamond but the geometry of how my data
interacts with these actually changes
it's very interesting okay so I want to
give you just a summary this is not
exhaustive of the ingredients of
compressed sensing okay so this is kind
of some of the theory and these are data
points that you can use when you're
thinking about how to apply compress
sensing to your problems in in
engineering so the first thing is your
signal your data must be sparse in some
transform based transform basis
fortunately virtually all data is unless
it looks like TV static or it's already
been compressed so even turbulent fluid
fields are sparse in some transform
basis lucky for engineers wavelets and
Fourier are good basis for most of the
signals were interested in so if you
just give me a fluid velocity field or
some climate measurements or vibrational
measurements you know from some system
they probably are going to be sparse in
Fourier and that's good for us because
that allows us to get away with sparse
few single pixel or spatially localized
measurements so our measurements have to
be incoherent with respect to this
transform basis and what that incoherent
means is that if my signal is sparse in
Fourier I shouldn't measure a single
tone sine wave because if I don't
measure the right nonzero sine wave I
get no other information from that
measurement it's a bad measurement
whereas if my system sparse in Fourier
and I measure a spatial Delta function
I've excited all Fourier freak
sieze and that's a good incoherent
measurement so that's great for for us
because single pixel measurements are
actually physically realizable I drop a
measurement in a physical location and
then there's bounds on how many
measurements I need depending on how
sparse we think our data is and there's
different different bounds on how many
measurements you need in different
literature but generally the idea is
that these measurements scale roughly
with the sparsity of your signal rather
than the ambient dimension of where that
signal lives which is good so the why
why this works if I'm going to just give
a sketch the reason is that the geometry
of sparse vectors is preserved with
these kinds of measurements so I have a
high dimensional system but in some
transform basis it's sparse or low
dimensional and the idea is that those
sparse vectors where you know at some
point all of my data could be written as
a sparse vector if I chose the right
basis the geometry of those sparse
vectors is preserved with good
incoherent measurements of which I have
sufficiently many and when I say the
geometry of sparse vectors is preserved
this means a few very concrete things so
there's this restricted isometry
property or principle the rip and what
this says is that the length of a sparse
vector is approximately preserved if I
have enough incoherent measurements and
outfalls of this restricted isometry
property are that I have basically I
preserve the inner product structure of
sparse vectors so if I have two data
vectors and I have you know they have
some sparse representation then the the
correlation of these two vectors are the
inner product of these two vectors is
preserved even when I compress down to a
much smaller measurement space so this
is hugely important because this means
that essentially my geometry my inner
product structure my distances between
data is preserved even when I massively
compress that data or down sample it
another cool outfall is that I can get
away with doing really fast numerical
linear algebra so even if I had access
to my full high dimensional data I can
compress that data do linear algebra on
the compressed space and I have this
property that the the fundamental
geometry the the structure is preserved
after that compression if I do the
compression in a sensible way and so
even if you aren't just down sampling
your data or taking a sparse measurement
of a system even if you had all of that
data you could still speed up your
processing using fast numerical linear
algebra on compressed representations
very cool just some ingredients to think
about how you can use this in your
system of interest and something I
really want to emphasize I think this is
incredibly important is that compressed
sensing is not just useful for images
it's not just useful in imaging science
or in statistics it's useful in
engineering so if I want to measure
tsunamis if I want to drop buoys in the
ocean if I want to measure weather
climate across the the globe if I want
to measure disease in Nigeria so this is
one of Josh Proctor's examples or if I
want to measure my flow field if I'm an
insect and I have strain sensors on my
wing and I want to measure my flow field
I I get single point measurements I get
to drop a measurement apparatus at a
certain physical location in space and
then I want to pull as much information
about that high dimensional system as
possible that's relevant for my
engineering tasks often that's a control
task okay but that's another talk so
there's lots of areas where compression
and compress sensing and sparsity can
give you direct immediate benefits and
engineering systems where you can
essentially take sparse measurements and
read between the lines to to essentially
fill in the gaps of your data that
that's expensive to measure this is a
cool example because any point
measurement might actually be quite
expensive either in terms of equipment
or actually getting that equipment out
in the ocean or
or in the case of the moth in terms of
the metabolic demand of having a strain
sensor on your wing or in the case of
measuring polio and Nigeria actually
putting you know a human to actually
measure disease the infrastructure
involved so that's just an overview of
compressed sensing with kind of a hint
of some of the engineering applications
there will be more videos diving into
some of these concrete applications like
compressed sensing and dynamic mode
decomposition which I know a number of
you are interested in we can use sparse
regression to identify nonlinear
dynamical systems from data we can also
use sparse representation to classify
different dynamical regimes of chaotic
systems lots of examples really there's
there's no bound to how you can use
sparsity in structured engineering
systems because the fact that they have
structure means that they're sparse in
some transform basis okay thank you very
much again all codes are available on my
website you can download them if you
have any questions don't hesitate to
contact contact me or any my
collaborators thank you very much